lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
encontrar cuál es el resultado de
389.000 2 - 76 1.151 como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de hacer esta resta por su cuenta no
importa si llegan a un resultado
diferente cuando lo hagamos juntos
entenderán mejor cómo obtener el
resultado y el procedimiento quedará
grabado en su memoria vamos a resolverlo
usando el método tradicional o el
algoritmo estándar algoritmo es una
palabra sofisticada para referirse a un
método lo primero que haremos es
escribir 389.000 2 y a esta cantidad le
vamos a restar 76 1.151 noten que lo
primero que hice fue alinear los dígitos
en su respectiva posición de valor las
unidades con las unidades las decenas
con las decenas las centenas con las
centenas los millares con los millares
las decenas de millar con las decenas de
millares y así sucesivamente ahora
estamos listos para hacer la resta lo
primero que haremos es fijarnos en las
unidades
tenemos dos unidades a las que le vamos
a quitar una unidad por lo que nos
quedaremos con una unidad las cosas se
ponen un poco más difíciles cuando
pasamos a las decenas como podemos
quitar cinco decenas a cero decenas no
pensaremos en esto durante un momento
pero veremos que tenemos el mismo
problema cuando vemos las centenas
tenemos que quitar una centena a cero
centenas ahora pasamos a los millares y
vemos que tenemos nueve millares y le
podemos quitar seis millares pero antes
de esto vamos a reagrupar para no tener
estos ceros aquí lo que voy a hacer será
reescribir estos nueve millares voy a
tomar un millar así que me quedarán ocho
millares y ese millar lo vamos a
reagrupar como diez centenas ahora son
diez centenas esto resuelve el problema
de las centenas pero seguimos teniendo
el problema de las decenas lo que
podemos hacer es tomar una de esas
centenas a las diez centenas de aquí le
quito una y me quedan nueve centenas y
esa centena la reagrupamos como diez
decenas y ahora sí puedo seguir restando
en las decenas tenemos diez decenas a
las que les quitamos 5
por lo que nos quedan cinco decenas
vemos la posición de las centenas donde
tenemos nueve centenas a las que les
quitamos una centena y nos quedan ocho
centenas pasamos a la posición de los
millares y a ocho millares les quitamos
seis millares quedando dos millares
ahora vemos la posición de las decenas
de millar donde tenemos ocho decenas de
millares a las que les quitamos siete
decenas de millar y nos quedan una
decena de millar finalmente llegamos a
la posición de las centenas de millares
donde tenemos estos trescientos mil con
esto terminamos la resta el resultado es
312 mil 851 aquí usamos el método
tradicional a veces es bueno que nos
aseguremos de que cada dígito arriba
esté en la posición correcta y sea mayor
o igual que el dígito que le vamos a
restar de cualquier manera al final
tendremos el mismo resultado y con esto
terminamos